bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où nous allons évidemment commenté
l'actualité mais peut-être aussi les
propositions qui seront celles des
candidats aux élections de 2017 on a
tout un tas de propositions à vous
montrer et à commenter et on va le faire
avec stéphane masse manceau s'est fait
un nom par les géants de l'université de
versailles saint crépin aux étangs
plateforme vous avez fait des wii était
surveillé un peu vos collègues d'un peu
partout en france où il faut pas faut
pas dire les choses comme ça il sera
fixé la musique c'est un peu ça je les
surveille
florence père cadet de versailles
espéces le droit du travail
on va parler peut-être encore une fois
de la loi elle comme rire peut-être pour
la dernière fois parce que oui je pense
qu'ils vont le remettre dans la poche
d'ici peu on va en parler avec vous et
plusieurs salles de douane ni un joli
terre avec votre dernière apparition qui
s'appelle dernière escale de sandra
martineau sur la joie ni évidemment
voilà un roman footballeur un roman
policier mais pas que voici l'histoire
d'un footballeur déchu
une ancienne star du barça et qui part
pour une croisière pour essayer de se
rabibocher que sa femme avec ses enfants
enfin c'est la croisière de la dernière
chance et donc tout se passe bien a
priori sauf que du côté l'été petit sa
soeur a été enlevé lé été témoin de sa
et sur le bateau ils croient voir le
le ravisseur et il a lui-même que
justifie de trois ans donc c'est une
sorte de huis clos pendant les visions
de la croisière et les avions persuadé
que le ravisseur est là et je vous dit
pas s'il est là ou pas mais enfin voila
c'est le rich des vivres s'il ya un
article récemment sur ces infos de
voleurs qui lui aussi a été un très bon
footballeur qui joue avec les plus
grands et qui est mort dans la rue c'est
assez terrible fin qui mordent enfin
deux solitaires croissance en sang en
france ont un sentiment de ne pas vous
et c'est devenu une terre de sdf
alors qu'il avait eu une carrière assez
incroyable c'est comme les gens qui
gagnent des sommes faramineuses de
l'auto ouais et qu' une dizaine d'années
après n'ont plus rien comme le dit mais
comment est-ce que comme en rêvait a
claqué tout sans rien gardé du tout
alors que si nous le donne sera qu'on
arrive à avoir quelques idées au babc le
mans enfin pas trop dépenser moi je
pourrais peut-être tout claquer mais je
garde un tout petit peu pour pour vivre
comme et l'a10 claque tout oui mais là
vous avez rêvé évidemment ce qui prouve
que vous êtes encore jeune mais les
galets qui protestent même avant ce sont
les jeunes sur les étudiants qui étaient
dans la rue jeudi pour protester contre
le projet de loi elle qu aubry qui est
pourtant été bien amendée par le
gouvernement mais ils étaient assez
nombreux dans la rue je propose war un
reportage sur ces manifestations et puis
on en parle ensuite
c'est leur 4e rassemblement à l'appel du
collectif jeunes 78 les lycéens et
étudiants chinois étaient réunis à
l'université versailles saint quentin ce
matin toujours dans leur ligne de mire
la loi travail
aujourd'hui on est encore sur l'analyse
que ça satisfait pas du tout la jeunesse
et les préoccupations la jeunesse sont
pas du tout pris en compte dans le cadre
de cette fois donc l'objectif pour
l'instant c'est d'obtenir un retrait de
la loi travail pour le mot négociation
impossible puisque c'est la base même du
projet de loi être ne convient pas c'est
l'esprit même de cette loi qui vise à
libéraliser un emploi un peu plus le
marché du travail qui vise à augmenter
la précarité des jeunes est donc temps
l'esprit même de cette loi on peut pas
l'accepter
le 24 mars dernier myriam el khomri la
ministre du travail a présenté au
conseil des ministres
une nouvelle mouture du projet de loi
pas encore suffisant pour les syndicats
en cette journée de mobilisation
nationale des étudiants ont été rejoints
par les cheminots de versailles
il faut faire absolument la jonction
étudiants lycéens et salariés en grève
quoi c'est hyper important c'est la clé
de la réussite pour faire vraiment
vaciller le gouvernement arrive à lui
faire retirer ce texte de loi qui
absolument mortifère pour le pour le
droit du travail mais aussi par des
biens placés nos propres revendications
progrès social les étudiants ont ensuite
rejoint le rassemblement parisien s'il
estime ne pas avoir obtenu satisfaction
ils envisagent de se rassembler à
nouveau le 5 avril prochain date de
l'examen approfondi du texte par la
commission des affaires sociales aulas
de médiation dans laquelle on voit
beaucoup de jeunes voix de quelques
fonctionnaires ou assimilés qui sont pas
directement concernés par la loi
il ya une mobilisation qui était tout de
même assez forte
j'en sais pas si on manquait enfin
content ou pas ils vont recevoir encore
les organisations de jeunes mais c'est
symptomatique qu'on va me de voir
combien cette mobilisation prend alors
même que ce que je dis est le projet de
boîte quand même été beaucoup abordé
beaucoup modifié je trouve ça plus
déprimant que symptomatique
lorsque et 15 jeunes est ce pareil ça me
fait extrêmement flippant mais que
veulent t'ils et on a l'impression qu'il
ya plus il n'y a pas de rêve il n'y a
plus rien que le seul truc c'est cdd cdi
acheter un appartement précarité cc des
thèmes qui devraient ça devrait même pas
leur traversée l'esprit un stage lac
merci j'espère que quand on fait des
études quand on en fait pas et qu'on a
18 ans on devrait avoir un autre rêve
que de savoir si on va pouvoir être en
cdi pour un boulot qui est pas forcément
passionnant enfin je veux dire c'est un
jeu passe sur la méconnaissance totale
qu'ils ont de la loi de toute façon si
on les interrogeait forme est incapable
de dire vraiment quel est le fond du
truc
et là le type qu'on a entendu qu'il
parle de nouveaux acquis ce de nouveaux
acquis sociaux a attrapé à décrocher et
c'est mon impression qui sont pas dans
le siècle on dirait presque que c'est ce
reportage aurait pu être fait il ya 15
ans clair que ces décès les mêmes la
couleur des drapeaux changez un tout
petit peu ils sont là toujours les mêmes
revendications des mots d une option qui
comprennent pas qu'on le siècle sans on
est quand même en demi siècle il faut
faire que des sacrifices c'est peut-être
un peu ça qui est la leur leurs
problèmes non mais oui il faudrait
qu'ils fassent cascastel bon maintenant
pourrait commencer par en faire au moins
de temps en temps alors qu'il quel
sacrifice est ce que ces étudiants ont
fait jusqu'à présent parle pas des
normes générales cette impression là
peut-être j'entendais quand même un
économiste qui est des philippines ion
qui a été professeur au collège de
france
et voilà il ya là dans cette loi on en a
parlé de flexi sécurité
il ya la flexibilité on la voit bien la
sécurité on la voit peut-être mieux et
moins il ya peut-être eu aussi cette
erreur dès le début de de l'annnonce de
la loi non oui enfin pour rebondir sur
ce que dit jean charles je pense que je
me sens différent il ya deux choix
différents la mondialisation sur la
mobilisation
je pense que ce qui est symptomatique au
delà du fait que je pense que les jeunes
peuvent se plaindre peut-être de la
précarité d'aujourd'hui puisqu'ils sont
systématiquement 80% embauchés en cdd
ils savent pas bien apprécié ce qu'on
reconduit en cdi ou pas donc aujourd'hui
la situation est certainement précaire
la loi elle connerie ne rend pas plus
précaire leur situation déjà je ne
comprends pas très bien mais ce qui est
symptomatique c'est qu'ils ne
comprennent pas la loi et comme vous le
dites il serait incapable d'en parler on
ne la connaissent pas parce que le
gouvernement ne l'a pas expliqué n'a pas
eu toute cette phase de pédagogie est
effectivement pour finir la boucle sur
la flexisécurité c'est que le
gouvernement est un gouvernement de
gauche auraient dû mettre les
partenaires sociaux autour de la table à
la fois sur la loi travail et sur la
problématique du chômage et de la prise
en compte du chômage qui permet d'avoir
les deux aspects de négociation en même
temps de la flexibilité d'un côté et de
la sécurité de l'autre alors qu'ils sont
allés franco sur cette loi du travail en
disant au départ on frappe de 49,3 on la
fera passer au forceps et en même temps
ils ont commencé à communiquer en disant
on est le pays d'europe qui est le pays
où on a la plus longue prise en charge
chômage d'europe et peut-être
faudrait-il réduire et je pense que tout
ça les gens ont mélangé en disant aux
lois travail plus en plus on va
peut-être nous rabotez la durée du
chômage et ça explose et on comprend
bien donc je pense qu'il ya une telle un
tel amateurisme et une telle incohérence
du gouvernement par rapport à ses
valeurs entre guillemets qu'on aboutit à
des situations comme celle-ci et on
aurait fait une négociation globale avec
les partenaires sociaux sur les deux
aspects travail et sécurité chômage ça
aurait été beaucoup plus intelligent je
pense que les gens auraient mieux
compris alors que les comprennent rien
allongeant le pratiquement rien d'un
projet de loi qui a été conçu dans le
l'ombre d'un cabinet seul et puis comme
ça qu'on sort de jour au lendemain sans
avoir concerté personne ni même ce qui
est assez bête les syndicats proches
comme la cmdt f1 au moins il n'y aurait
plus amadoué je te dis que tu es le plus
large de fil pour finir quelques
le déclarer valls enfin en disant je
vais recevoir l'unef et je suis prêt à
prendre en compte leurs revendications
eric mc5 était incroyable on a
l'impression d'un amateurisme total
stéphane series étudiants qu'on avait
été réunie chez vous non non patrice ans
alors chez moi avec un réseau minuscule
mais non les étions chez moi ça serait
un peu petit pourquoi pas mais la
diversité à l'université mais c'est pas
j'ai pas la totalité des états n'ont
rien entendu
vous vous doutez bien que les étudiants
en droit eux travaillent là vous allez
tu dis alors pour beaucoup d'entre eux
oui parce qu'ils l'ont lu et ils ont au
moins les enterrer la comprendre ils ont
étudié mais je j'entends jean charles
il a une jeunesse qui n'a plus de rêve
etc je vous confirme moi qui fréquentent
la jeunesse d'assez près enfin moi qui
suis même d'ailleurs jeunes qui en fait
partie mais j'ai quand même encore
quelques rêves mais les jeunes les plus
jeunes que je fréquente à l'université
en effet je vous le confirme et ils sont
plutôt dans le stress dans l' angoisse
du lendemain
alors on peut en effet peut-être
comprendre au regard de la place que
notre société laisse à la jeunesse enfin
la jeunesse je sais pas trop ce que
c'est mais enfin le gardon ce concept là
un peu abstraitement je ne veux pas dire
que tout fout l'camp pour les jeunes et
que c'était mieux avant mais peut-être
ça je pense que peut-être dessous
arrêtées sont de plus dur quand il
arrive dans une société dans laquelle on
ne les attend pas personne ne les temps
et en hébreu
rien n'est fait pour eux je me rends
déclaration je ne sais plus si j'en ai
déjà parlé ici mais il ya deux ans un
étudiant vient me voir en me disant
voilà on vient de me refuser un stage
c'est un stage d'un étudiant cinquième
année ne sais pas c'était pas pour faire
du café et faire des photocopies
c'est mon amant pour l'étudiant était
entre guillemette parfaitement
employables très compétent et la grande
entreprise dans laquelle il avait
postulé pour son stage lui a répondu
monsieur on ne prend des stagiaires que
sous réserve qu'il puisse démontrer une
expérience une expérience
pour un stage payé à 400 et 500 euros au
titre
en effet personne ne les attend mais sur
cette affaire je crois que je rejoins
aussi ce que disait florence c'est une
c'est une histoire très mal ficelé est
très mal bouclé moi j'ai l'impression
que ce genre de textes politiquement il
faut le présenter en début de
quinquennat faut pas attendre la fin
surtout la fin tel quel ce telle qu'elle
est en train de se dérouler sous les
yeux espèce de déliquescence adam
incroyable et puis alors voir en effet
les cheminots qui rejoignent les
étudiants il ya toujours derrière ça
cette espèce de mythe historico
sociologico sentimentale aux politiques
de mai 68 mais vous ignorez vous voyez
les étudiants ouvriers alors billancourt
renault n'est plus à billancourt médiane
moi c'est toujours à voir ces drapeaux
de ces assemblées générales d'ailleurs
qui sont très souvent des deux vrais
spectacles
seulement on ne peut pas s'exprimer où
il y en a certains qui s'exprime ou
simplement où il est interdit de poser
certaines questions où les votes se
déroule de manière assez surréaliste
j'en ai vécu comment gérer pour le coup
tout petit bon cru plus jeune mais je
vois que les choses de ce point de vue
là non pas deux mais là ça change pas et
d'ailleurs de la personne qui était
interviewé le cheminot a dit que c'était
pour faire tomber le gouvernement
il a parlé il a parlé de la loi bien
juste avant il a dit faire tomber le
gouvernement et après faire tomber la
loi c'était la lutte je crois qu'il faut
que de gaulle comprennent qu'il faut
qu'il y en aa à aa après après peut-être
de le seul crédit qu'on puisse accorder
à tous ces jeunes c'est que parmi les
innombrables promesses non tenues du
président enfin du conseil avait quand
même dit la jeunesse et des vérités les
jeunes seront beaucoup plus heureux en
2017 qui nous laisse en 2012
là on peut voir que c'est il ya
peut-être un léger sentiment de trahison
de la part des jeunes qu'ils ont c'est
encore une fois bien foutu de nous bon
après c'était un peu le défaut de la
jeunesse et de croire à peu près
n'importe quoi mais bon c'est un peu ce
que beaucoup de gens ont fait
visiblement vote hollande donc
mais comment on peut expliquer quand
même parce qu'on on a des on a des
expériences qui ont déjà été tentées je
pense aux cpe de dominique de villepin
c'était exactement pas et sept avaient
été réglées dans un coin d'inde et du de
matignon m
et voilà et ça a donné la même chose
c'est-à-dire des manifestations y ait
pas eu de concertation avant donc on est
quand même informé de la façon dont on
pourrait gouverner quand même c'est ça
qui est bizarre on a l'impression qu'il
réécrive une page blanche à chaque fois
oui je pense qu'ils s'imaginent toujours
que ça va passer qui est un peu plus
finaud que les précédents et que c'est
pas je pense que valent peut se dire moi
je suis pas villepin je lui suis bien
bien différent d'un supérieur
gouvernement népalais mais choisit son
labo lui et voilà
et puis et puis on peut imaginer que
dans dans cinq ans le prochain premier
ministre pour faire la même boulette et
exploiter de la même façon je pense
quand même
en même temps ces deux les mêmes
ressorts psychologiques c'est à dire que
will points vous les a montrés à sarkozy
que c'était lui le réformiste je me
demande s'ils veulent que n'a pas voulu
montrer à macron que lui aussi était un
réformiste mais la seule chose c'est le
choix que le gouvernement n'a pas vu au
travers de cette loi la jeunesse arriver
autant pour le cpe comme ça contrat
première embauche s'était directement
message alors sa courte victoire mais je
la pousse à lui directement les gens n'a
rien dit que la qui l'ont pas vu durée
ou non ils ont compté japon par rapport
à la loi le coma il serait dans la
richesse qui prouve à peu ce sont
vraiment des amateurs parce que ils sont
quand même très proche de l'unef donc
qui n'est pas compris enfin oui certains
enfin valls n'est pas franchement très
proche de hollande 1 quand même encore
quelques relais au psg comme beaucoup de
gens du ps qui sont d'anciens leaders
lycéens et d'enseignants
donc ce que l'on peut voir comme ils
n'ont pas consulté donc la cfdt au
départ et c'est par votre avis
est ce que parce qu'on va parler
peut-être de la vie constitutionnelle
après est-ce qu'on est partis pour que
le pouvoir remettre cette loi dans sa
poche
parce que la salle est compliqué la
gauche
en tout cas la gauche de la gauche
contre la droite qui étaient prêtes à
voter la première mouture semble pas
prête du tout à voter la mouture
actuelle du texte
donc on vraiment le rapport de forces au
parlement mais françois hollande à sa
phrase toute faite
enfin c'est ce qu'il a dit pour la
déchéance de nationalité le fait de ne
pas convoquer le congrès il met tout ça
sur le dos de la droite voilà j'ai
essayé mais voilà si la droite veut pas
voter c'est la gauche n'est pas le cas
donc il risque de se passer c'est le
texte sera voté mais totalement vidée de
son talent en vigueur on a déjà tous
surtout des choses mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont en train de
partir encore sur une erreur parce que
madame elle comme rignac commence à
expliquer pour licenciement pour motif
économique on dirait que pour les
grandes entreprises
ah oui on partirait sur six ou huit
rimeize de déficit et pour les petites
capes trimestre elle va passer au crible
du conseil constitutionnel si elle
recommence la même bêtise on va retomber
encore dans le même travers donc ils
disent que les juristes planchent sur le
sujet mais est ce que ça vous choque
réveillère c'est parce que totalement
idiot que que les petites entreprises ne
soient pas astreintes aux mêmes
contraintes et mairie d'ascain il ya
d'autres critères économiques à prendre
en compte dans ce cas on prend un
critère de trésorerie on prend un
critère qui n'est pas forcément qu'une
dégradation de châssis on a une
dégradation dans une petite entreprise
s'il ya une dégradation du chiffre
d'affaires qui s'écroule la trésorerie
elle part en fumée très vite dans une
grande entreprise là si une baisse de
chiffre d'affaires la trésorerie par
pans fumer aussi vite donc il suffit de
prendre le bon critère économique plutôt
que de dire si c'est une petite c'est 4
trimestre chiffre d'affaires qui
dégringole et si c'est une grande ces
six là on va partir sur un problème est
que le conseil constitutionnel il suffit
de trouver un autre critère économique
pertinent qui puisse dans un cas comme
dans l'autre ne pas s'appliquer à peu
près au même moment parce que le
problème des petites entreprises qui
vont mal c'est un problème de cash pour
ça
je donc est double d'où l'importance
peut-être pour eux de savoir à quoi ils
pourraient être condamnés en kabylie
chic un peu les politiques sont un tout
petit peu imaginatif et ouais mais c'est
vrai que pour l'homme de l'égalité de
tous devant la loi
c'est la constitution c'était pas de
vous disiez l'instant que voilà de cette
réforme elle tombe raide aurait
peut-être fallu la faire au début du
quinquennat ouest dirno bon on a encore
un peu de pouvoir politique dont on
vient d'assister à l'épisode de la
révision constitutionnelle avorté
là encore c'est une impuissance totale
et du pouvoir peut-être des calculs de
partido de la part de 2,2 du président
hollande qui pensaient que la déchéance
de sa nationalité serait retoqué par le
conseil d'état ce qui n'a pas été le cas
et peut-être de la droite on est quand
même et de la droite sénatoriale
notamment ou alors c'était cette affaire
ça m'inspire de faim de réflexion et je
dire de ce que vous dites c'est que
d'abord sur un plan institutionnel
je je enfin je trouve et on n'a pas
vraiment entendu ce son de cloche après
pâques
moi je me félicite plutôt de voir
comment les choses se sont passées c'est
à dire que on a des institutions alors
j'ai entendu ces derniers jours qu'ils
sont bloquante qui doivent être révisés
la vème république
mais je trouve que c'est quand même pas
si mal fait parce que tout cela nous
montre que réviser la constitution c'est
quelque chose de lourd de grave qu'on ne
touche pas à la constitution comme ça
tous les quatre matins surtout dans des
considérations d'affect aussi aussi
forte et que pour réviser la
constitution il va falloir que le
titulaire du pouvoir suprême le
président de la république de la
république se heurte à d'autres pouvoirs
que qu'un type tout seul dans son coin
ne puisse pas accomplir une chose aussi
grave qu'une révision constitutionnelle
moi ça me rassure plus non
on comprend ce qu'on devrait toujours
sur le plan institutionnel d'ailleurs
il faut bien avoir à l'esprit que ce set
cette physionomie des chèques de
révision constitutionnelle n'est pas une
nouveauté alors j'ai pas fait le
décompte mais on doit pas être loin
d'une dizaine depuis le début des années
soixante dix huit erreurs et alors
mitterrand sur notamment la le contrôle
de constitutionnalité a posteriori
pompidou dans les années 70 sur la
réforme du quinquennat n'est pas arrivé
il s'est également heurté au sénat en
dépit de la concordance politique entre
l'assemblée et le sénat
donc je pense que tout ça montre que les
institutions d'un cinquième un public
sur ce point là en tout cas sont
suffisamment robustes et raisonnable
pour que une révision constitutionnelle
se fasse pas comme ça sur un coin de
table
sur le plan politique moi j'ai
l'impression que ça montre enfin ça
montre surtout une chose et je lisais
les analyses de du cevipof
hier à ce sujet-là marquant le rejet
profond alors ce n'est pas une nouveauté
mais ça semble s'aggraver des français à
l'égard du couple hollande sarkozy les
français n'en veulent plus ils veulent
tourner la page et j'ai l'impression que
cette l'échec de cette réforme de cette
révision marque un peu cette espèce de
rejet parce qu'on sait très bien que du
côté du sénat ce sont plutôt les
fillonnistes qui rejetait ont rejeté
alors que les sarkozystes y avait une
histoire le sinaï photo francois on sait
que monsieur larcher à la rue taux de
ceux de ce bord là et puis du côté du
côté de dowland au problème c'est la
gauche c'est pas c'est pas la droite qui
elle était prête plutôt aussi à le
suivre
donc moi j'y vois politiquement un
désaveu très forts de ce couple dont les
français ne veulent plus c'est en tout
cas tout à fait intéressant parce qu'on
oublie c'est que au delà de la date d'un
point de vue droit et politique c'est le
thème même de toutes ces interventions
c'est la déchéance de nationalité
parce que du coup là et où est ce qu'on
peut se passer de la constitution pour
déchoir de sa nationalité qui on veut on
peut s'en passer aussi sur l'état
d'urgence voilà donc voilà donc c'est
pour ça que
c'est quand même beaucoup de bruit pour
pas grand chose parce que on pouvait
tout à fait et ont pu faire sans ça
revient sur l'intérêt politique c'est
vraiment un jeu à somme nulle part on se
dit mais je reviens ce que bardot à ce
que dit stéphane et est-ce que c'est pas
justement le problème qu'on a dans ses
institutions ou à la fois il ya un
certain nombre de mécanismes qui est
démocratique qu'il faut que bon on peut
pas faire ce qu'on veut et en même temps
une demande politique ou une habitude
politique est ce que le président de la
vème république soit un puncheur de
mozart qui peut décider de ce qu'il veut
quand il veut bien sur mes skis a pas
une contradiction entre les ajustements
oui il ya une culture il ya une culture
politique alors la cinquième république
et pour beaucoup d'ailleurs
et de ce point de vue là on a
l'impression que la cinquième jour
contre son camp sur la c'est ce que
voulait l'esprit de la vème république
avec de gaulle dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est c'est la restauration de
l'autorité de l'état et à la tête de
l'état la restauration d'une d'une
autorité visible d'une autorité
directement responsable devant le corps
électoral
on parle de la concision de 1962 un du
jour où le président de la république a
été éligible parlant l'entièreté du
corps électoral
il ya je sais même pas un paradoxe c'est
à dire que j'entends parler depuis deux
jours de l'impuissance présidence
enfin réalisons deux secondes de quoi on
parle on parle ici d'une autorité du
président de la ligue française qui est
sans doute dans les démocraties
l'autorité qui dispose du plus gros tu
plus large et d'aidés des pouvoirs les
plus importants le président
l'appliquent française est infiniment
plus puissant dans son état que nous
l'est le président des italiens par
exemple qui qui qui pour le coup lui est
un président qui parfois est totalement
nue totalement impuissant peut-être en
egypte où la dir ont suivi la série
vraie mission du lanceur et la liste ils
sont très bas donc il ya bien sûr bien
sûr les ombres glh et les petites
histoires de
il faut il faut quelqu'un comme ça
qu'ils qui dispose de pouvoirs forts les
gens sont aussi très rapide a dénoncé
souvenez vous de l'histoire de
l'hyperprésident et cela crie temps mais
qu'on adresse
sans ça je disais est ce qu a pas de
contradiction parce qu'on est toujours
un peu entre les autres une demande d'un
pouvoir fort est en même temps une
besoin de démocratie et on n'est
toujours pas lancé dans une démocratie
je sais pas trop si si les gens ont
conscience de ce que ça peut représenter
gîte pas que les gens sont des crétins
mais je pense que ça fonctionne détrôné
la vie politique locale c'est exactement
la même source c'est à dire que les gens
ne conçoivent pas que leur mère c'est
paraît-il l'autorité préféré des
français
pourtant la réalité d'un maire c'est la
plupart du temps quelle que soit sa
couleur politique son caractère et sa
tournure d'esprit c'est que le maire
dans son coin
soit tout seul soit avec deux trois
copains de son bord politique fait ce
qu'il veut il a une autoroute un
boulevard devant lui pendant six ans
avec un conseil municipal composé comme
il est qui ne sert à rien ce n'est que
ce n'est qu'une espèce de théâtre le
conseil municipal
alors on dit ça se passe au parlement
donc pourquoi pas au conseil municipal
mais les gens sont satisfaits de cela ce
sont des situations parfaitement
insupportable qui choque
d'ailleurs certains de mes collègues
étasunien j'en ai reçu à apa il ya pas
longtemps et on en parlait de cela les
étrangers comment vous tolérez serait
donc justement cette histoire le ici le
prénom d'un public a buté sur le
parlement sur l'une des deux chambres du
parlement dont on dit justement depuis
des années depuis des décennies qu'elle
servait à rien de bon là je trouve que
le bicaméralisme montre la splendeur de
son utile verra ce qu'il faudrait pas
faire comme je faisais de gaulle c'est à
dire sauter au dessus des du parlement
est allé consulter carrément les
français par référendum
quant au mois il avait la majorité sauf
que là on retombe sur la question
référendaire pas figé la pâte en soit la
fin sur la question des salaires dans
lequel vous le savez vous en êtes aussi
bien convaincu que moi que celui qui a
le pouvoir c'est pas celui qui répond
mais c'est celui qui poseraient castrés
et qu'on peut voter très bien contre
speed il pose la question exactement
rien rajouter parce que stéphane a été
est ce que très très intéressant dont je
voulais juste dire que j'ai pas compris
pourquoi il s'est bien voulu faire une
réforme de la constitution sur un sujet
qui était déjà réglé à mais c'était un
calcul politique je crois oui une force
symbolique symbolique y avait aussi la
volonté de rassembler peut-être enfin on
peut mettre sa marque et de marquer un
peu l'histoire parce qu'on vous dit pas
oui c'est un regret à la fin il y avait
mes sincères avec panache et de
l'ampleur mais ce que alors on pourrait
parler d'autre chose et puis
mais est ce que est ce que tout ça au
faux pas ce qu'on voit où il ya vous
avez réseau qu'est la démocratie
fonctionnelle m'enfin on peut pas mettre
de côté les calculs politiques et d'un
côté et de l'autre
est ce que quand même c'est pas le front
national une fois encore qui sort
vainqueur de cet épisode quoi finalement
la gauche et la droite n'arrive pas
parce qu'il ya aussi sa pelouse en
politiques n'arrivent pas à se mettre
d'accord pour une mesure qui est censé
quand même lutter contre des terroristes
contre le terrorisme c'est que sinon je
crois que peu de gens comprennent
vraiment ce qui vient de se passer est
que ce à quoi on comprend pas du tout
puisque les gens quand même si les sang
et or étaient d'accord pour qu'il y ait
un accord et le labo flamande sur une
façon de lutter alors est-ce que c'est
efficace pas efficace des bars mais
contre contre le terrorisme non mais
c'est pas nous pour répondre à votre
question des choses que pour une fois le
front national là dedans il veut être
complètement à côté de la plaque
les électeurs du front national aussi
avait pas savoir le comtal mascouche
quoi même pas la face rock en tout cas
le front national n'a rien à espérer de
ce
ce petit moment politique et ce ratage
non jeu et kantari berthe ans sur nombre
de 4000 euros
ce prétexte qu'il est mené sans mandat
sans vague être député voit là puisqu'il
est contre le cumul des mandats
là je vais à ce que l'accès il a bien
compris ce qui se passait je vais plus
dans le national doit apprécier à sa
juste valeur
c'est quand même assez n'ont pas moyens
il ya deux choses dire que ça me choque
pas que toi qui gagnes famille qui gagne
sa vie que soient bien encore une fois
très choquant c'est que c'est lié d'une
extrême maladresse
c'est idiot c'est pas le bon moment
c'est pas la façon c'est ces voix là et
puis elle pouvait attendre six mois il
ya un an il ya d'autres moments d'autres
façons etc malhabile et c'est choquant
pour en plus une région qui est
favorisée qui voit vraiment ce que c'est
que le chômage la case zéro voilà c'est
vous que c'est beaucoup c'est pour tous
et c'est quand même temps que lui il
appelle ça un complément de salaire vous
le salaire médian
il ya beaucoup de gens qui double le
triple de ce qui est prévu qu'un vrai
que ce ses 4000 euros soit les revenus
du foyer
ben voilà il serait très heureux ce
petit complément et curieux alors me
direz que ça moins que les 5 millions et
quelques uns des pdg de peugeot bonne
voie en tout cas la scène lasser le
public
comme dirait est bon et je les avais été
là ils nous diraient que c'est vrai que
cette augmentation là aussi elle doit
mal passé pour beaucoup de risques c'est
lé moment voilà ce que le type et
redresser la la la la la la boîte avec
les lettres de l'état quand même où pour
une fois ci avec en demandant de
sacrifices aussi aux salariés
c'est le moment tout ça est fait de
façon un peu curieuse
après si on est un peu intelligent et
qu'on prend un peu de recul on peut voir
que c'est quand même le patron le moins
payé de tous les grands constructeurs
automobiles mondiaux
il est payé deux fois moins que le
je crois quatre fois moins que le pdg de
volkswagen il a quand même fait moins de
bêtises il est payé 10 fois moins que le
pdg de general motors veut dire il est
payé deux fois moins que le pdg de
renault voilà voilà
tout ça était effectivement choquantes
et saison l'été était irréprochable mais
visiblement c'est pas un mauvais nom
cerveau voilà donc après effectivement
ce que c'est maladroit c'est seulement
quand on pouvait tout à fait penser
qu'on peut se satisfaire de deux
millions et demi au maroc pendant six
mois de plus ou moins les rats mais
voilà on dit pourquoi ça va mieux pour
tout le monde
voilà un peu gêné en fin de mois mais
pas ailleurs dans un peu écourté ses
vacances
vous avez un bon été relaté ou en face
parce qu'il ya une chose qui n'en n'ont
oui oui / lesure xavier bertrand moi je
vais fins et je ne sens pas je comprends
ça comme une sorte de virginité mais oui
avec l'élection j'ai compris j'ai
compris et il a presque dit j'ai changé
ou presque à la façon de sarkozy enfin
c'est pas nous c'est pas une obsession
je sais pas pourquoi je parle toujours
de bons mais non mais non mais mais mais
mais mais mais mais ça pousse quand même
la question de la question des suites à
donner à la fin du cumul des mandats
enfin la fin la fin supposée parce que
je ne sais pas si si le texte tiendra au
cours de la prochaine législature
mais en tout cas des politiques qui
cumulent moins deux mandats ça suppose
au regard de la professionnalisation
inévitable des mandats politiques des
indemnités de mandats plus élevé c'est
très clair mais à ce point là peut-être
pas et pas de cette façon là on va
d'abord il fallait le dire avant il
fallait l'annoncer au corps électoral
mais s'est échangé mais le vrai 4000
euro discutent argument électoral pour
voir non mais bien sûr mais on peut voit
là où j'ai des rêves je suis encore
jeune homme est allé y est une chose
assez intéressante aussi en politique
c'est la multiplication des candidatures
je pensais que vous allez dire je sais
pas mais c'est parce que la
multiplication des candidatures aux
primaires de la droite et geoffroy
didier et il ya eu on va l'entendre
monsieur jean frédéric poisson et ce
n'est pas un poisson d'avril
je pense que l'immense majorité des
candidats qui se sont présentés sinon
tous étaient membres du gouvernement
en mai 2012 lorsque nous avons perdu les
échéances présidentielles et
législatives
d'une manière ou d'une autre leur
responsabilité est engagée dont ce qui a
été notre défaite au printemps il ya
quatre ans et deuxièmement le message
que je porte jusqu'ici n'a pas
d'équivalent je suis un candidat qui
affirme ne pas enfin je ne veux pas
donner plus de droits qu'il me faut à
logique de marché je ne me suis pas
libérables je ne suis pas atlantiste je
ne suis pas fédéraliste
sur le plan européen alors que tous mes
autres concurrents le sont voilà il est
pas pareil que les autres donc il n'a
pas les mêmes idées mais quand même elle
n'a pas changé mais lui n'a pas changé
non mais alors évidemment tous ces
candidats qui se présentent là il y en
aura très peu qui auront le droit de
participer aux réalités aux primaires
parce qu'il faut le parrainage de 20
députés d'un certain nombre de militants
et qui n'auront probablement pas oui
d'autant que les grands candidats les 4
ce qui en a quatre maliens les liens bad
mais il y avait encore ben disons les
quatre candidats auxquels on pense juppé
le maire vion sarkozy voilà vont rafler
beaucoup plus qu'il ne le dois oui ça
fait vingt députés minimum voile alors
pas d'avoir histoire qualifié avec nash
et accessoirement de vider le réservoir
pour les uns pour les autres visions de
il semblerait qu'une crème et du mal qui
fait que maintenant les députés
soutiennent doivent signer la même
profession fois que les gens qui ont
voté à la primaire savoir qu'il veut
trouve pour l'alternance se le dise en
dida de la droite du centre ça je trouve
ça très bien parce que là c'était
vraiment un truc pour faire voter front
national
quand on dit ne pas y porter sa part sur
son nom mais que nkm puisse espérer être
faire signer se faire parrainer par un
député du parti socialiste mais on
pourrait en dire autant des quais mais
où est-on quand même quelle est la
logique
un socialiste va dire oui je pense que
prenait fin le bon candidat c'est une
canne c'est quand même aussi bizarre de
changer les règles du jeu quand on
s'aperçoit que ça pourrait favoriser un
candidat
reprise amorcée avant ça fait quand même
13 ans tiennent mieux vaut tard que
jamais quand on s'aperçoit d'une énorme
commun il fait moins honnêtement moi ça
me choque c'est pas un député des
républicains de choisir le candidat
socialiste à la primaire et c'est
l'inversé mais c'est en étant entraîneur
allemand alors comment on va mesurer que
les gens qui vont voter à la primaire
vont forcément voté pour le candidat
dans des centres on peut pas ben si
parce qu'il ya une main non bio c'est
nécessairement des citoyens de gauche
qui ont publié des gens là étaient
bonnes à gauche il ya cette promesse
idiote que l'on fait quand on va voter
aux primaires socialistes ont fait la
même la même promesse idiote
quand on va aller voter pour la primaire
des républicains qui toute façon les
primaires c'est une idiotie
ça serait drôle moi je trouve ça drôle
que nkm et ses vins des ptf des gens de
des écologistes et des gens de gauche
qui disent oui je frappe comme étant que
le personne ne veut le plus gros
problème est qu'elles se présentent
nkm primaire des écolos ça fera une
quelqu'un d'intelligent et de compétent
je ne veux pas que l'on et puis voilà ça
sera parfait
donc c'est dans je ne sais pas si vous
ne trouvez qu'elle ait pas non mais je
rêve travailler parmi des gens très bien
républicain et les légitimes partout où
elle va lui moi je trouve intelligente
et plus tôt et tout à fait brillant
ce que je trouve illégitime c'est de
vouloir se faire parrainer par des gens
qui n'ont pas son partenaire année par
20 députés s'étaient en partie oui mais
voilà bellino mission convainc pas de
son propre parti
c'est que si on n'est pas dans le bon
parti soit fonds créé un autre mais
honnêtement non alors autres élections
ce sont les élections à l'université
présidence de l'université parce qu'il
ya un président sortant qui jouit
vestiaire et il ya donc ici
jean-luc vestiaires pendant et face à
lui la monsieur guillemot réguler il dit
guy mobile va les écouter tous les deux
si vous voulez puis new delhi nous
expliquer un petit peu comment tout ça
se passe si vous êtes d'accord je peux
pas dire que les résultats ne satisfasse
pleinement puisque donc je pensais que
nous que je pourrais faire un meilleur
score en terme d'élus
alors maintenant ce qu'on constate c'est
que les résultats ne sont pas non plus
très très clair et très doux très
déséquilibré ne baisse pas les bras
c'est à dire ce que je pense que je peux
essayer de rassembler rassembler donc
évidemment exemple ont voté pour moi a
quant à lui des élus de minus
éventuellement les élus des autres dit
et qui donne aux étudiants et appris à
la question quel de l'extérieur qui se
pose de films
il ya une vraie envie de la communauté
universitaire d'aller de l'avant
voilà c'est à dire que nous avons fait
campagne sur un projet pas du tout sur
arget et ce projet qui est assez claire
emporter l'adhésion
je pense que c'est ça comme on peut dire
à l'issue du scrutin
on nous a un fils quentin hume
transparente sur un projet avec l'idée
de rassembler et maintenant il va nous
falloir rassembler au delà des
différentes listes parce que c'est de
l'université dont il s'agit et ce
travail commence dès aujourd'hui
alors on parlait de vote
boyd a expliqué au cours de laquelle
votre vie alors oui les les
les autorités universitaires sont élus
par la communauté universitaire depuis
le xiiie siècle alors avec quelques
parenthèses dont les régimes
autoritaires les autorités étaient
nommés donc c'est une une tradition très
forte qui caractérise vraiment la
gouvernance universitaire sachant que
l'élection a lieu l'élection du
président de l'université a lieu donc
tous les quatre ans et que c'est une
élection au suffrage indirect à savoir
que les composantes de la communauté
universitaire c'est à dire les
enseignants chercheurs les étudiants et
les administratifs vote chacun pour des
listes et les candidats à ces listes
postulent pour siéger dans pour
simplifier les choses dans deux grands
conseils de grande instance le conseil
d'administration qui est l'organe comme
son ensemble indique l organe majeur de
l'établissement qui délibère
sur les grandes orientations sur les
questions budgétaires etc et puis
d'autre part le conseil académique qui
lui est plus compétent en matière à la
fois de recherche et de pédagogie et
donc le président de l'université est
élu par l'ensemble des élus du conseil
d'administration alors la situation
actuelle c'est que nous avons voté la
semaine dernière pour l'élection de nos
représentants au sein de ces deux
concerts et que le 10 mai le conseil
d'administration doit se réunir alors il
pas encore complet il faut le compléter
par des personnalités extérieures
voilà qui sont cooptés par les membres
élus et donc le 10 mai le conseil
d'administration doit choisir un
président alors pour l'instant il ya
deux candidats le président sortant
jean-luc vestiaire qui est professeur de
biologie et didier guillemot qui est
donc professeur à la faculté de médecine
sachant que les résultats donnent une
lecture extrêmement confuse
c'est les analystes les résultats en
gros sur pour l'instant sur un conseil
d'administration qui pour l'instant est
composé de 22 élus on est à peu près à
11,11 si vous voulez à 11 partout serrés
élections nécessairement serré pour
l'instant incertaine et qui sera
peut-être un peu alors qui pourrait se
faire par les personnalités extérieures
sachant que quand même je trouverais ça
un peu gênant s'ils voulaient se serait
pas illégal mais du point de vue de la
légitimité et si j'ose dire de la
tradition universitaire ce ne serait pas
tout à fait dans les clous
le fait est que les listes porter est
conduite par didier guillemot du côté
des enseignants chercheurs des
professeurs et des maîtres de
conférences et assimilés sont arrivés en
tête
ça c'est une donnée c'est pour moi une
donnée assez forte qui marque ainsi que
l'a reconnu jean du vestiaire que a
il espérait sans doute des résultats un
peu meilleurs mais la grande conclusion
qu'on peut en tirer si vous voulez c'est
que les résultats sont très
très très flou très difficile et
qu'est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un blocage
où il ya des procédures qu'il faut que
tu fais un blocage c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
parvienne pas à aimer le président au
jeu je fais confiance au conseil
d'administration
forcément que ça le sera forcément l'un
des deux non non absolument pas on a
déjà vu y compris à lui j'ai ce qu un
troisième larron qui sort du chapeau
dernier moment et qui peuvent et ben on
verra bien donc
réponse le 10 mai à saint denis mais
toujours des élections là je ne sais pas
si l'université passera de l'ombre à la
nominer
en tout cas c'est le 10 mars est dit
mais peut-être en mousse sais pas si
vous avez vu sur les marques qu'il faut
des modes manière et islamiques wyss la
liste avec des maillots de bain couvrant
tout le corps et c est ce qui a suscité
la colère à la fois de pierre bergé est
à la fois de la ministre lance rossignol
vous avez vu danser mais moi c'est
d'abord je suis ravi de ce que je sais
c'est quand même assez rare pour être
dits responsables de la part de ces
marques at elle dit la ministre a été
très très bien sur ce coup là la régie
vite c'était clair et net elle elle
s'oppose à sa scandaleuse elle a mille
fois raison
elles ont peu et des mots alors bien
évidemment tout le monde enfin levée de
bouclier fiscal oser utiliser le mot
brique dans sa déclaration de
façon tout à fait sensé justifier il y
avait absolument aucun problème à ça
c'était une référence à l'assassinât en
parler de ses membres
parler de l'esclavagé qualité ragon vu
comme moody's quand césar a parlé de
négritude il a peu à parler de gens de
couleur attitude ou de bonsoir été
ridicules
donc ça déjà là dessus c'est extrêmement
donc laurence rossignol bravo et puis
deuxièmement et ça ça nécessite aussi
d'être signalé pierre bergé a prend une
position intelligente et bien éclairé là
c'est bien aussi
et sur le fond bien évidemment que c'est
scandaleux
donc moi je trouve qu'il faudrait
boycotter tous ses magasins qui vendent
de l'apport de donner les marques note
max heinzer dolce gabbana uniqlo et h&m
voilà j'ai pu mettre les pieds dans ses
boutiques c'est tout moi je ne suis pas
d'accord
alors j'ai pourtant je suis la seule
femme autour de ces variables
vous avez droit taux de change et
réduisent
il n'y a pas de problème soyez là il ya
deux choses pour rebondir sur ce qu'a
dit laurence rossignol alors moi j'ai
été extrêmement choqué de ces propos
c'est pas tellement le propos n'est
alors j'ai repris in extenso les propos
pour que ne pas l'aider formé où elle a
dit bien sûr qu'il ya des femmes qui
choisissent
il y avait aussi des américains
qui étaient pour l'esclavagé et moi ce
qui me choque c'est pas qu'elle utilise
le mot parce qu'elle s'est
expliqué là-dessus c'est qu'elle fasse
une comparaison qui me paraît
complètement inadaptés puisque
l'esclavagiste et des millions de morts
je veux dire qu'est ce qu'on va comparer
un problème parce qu'il ya deux
problèmes mais le problème de la mode et
puis le problème de fond qui le problème
de femmes qui doivent en faire mais leur
corps pour ne pas le montrer mais non
mais non pas de 10 mètres là on parle de
deux vêtements lapointe donc moi je
trouve que je trouve très choquant
d'obliger des femmes à cacher leurs
corps
mais aujourd'hui on a des femmes moi je
trouve ça terrifiant quand on voit une
femme avec ces espèces de robes qui sont
comme des sacs beige ou marron qui sont
absolument immonde
je me dis que je suis plutôt contente
pour celles qui choisissent parce qu'il
ya des femmes qui choisissent aussi de
ne pas de ne pas montrer leur corps et
de s'habiller de cette manière là il ya
des femmes qui sont contraintes et je
pensais la majorité qui sont contraintes
mais pour les femmes qui choisissent de
cacher leurs corps je trouve que c'est
bien qu'on puisse avoir une mode qui met
aussi en valeur leur corps parce que ces
espèces de sakuya on voit rien c'est
horrible
alors que là ils vont faire des
vêtements qui met une transition voilà
ça mais non mais oui il a dit cela me
joly burqa mais ça ne m'a demandé ça lui
ça ne banalise pas ça permet je crois
qu'un jeu
non mais la burqa et avec le grillage et
pas tolérer en france mais je pense
qu'on peut parce que là on parle de
maillots de bain moi j'étais il ya pas
très longtemps au bord de la mer j'ai vu
des femmes qui portaient des maillots de
bain c'est comme des comme s'il allait
faire de la peau des flambées c'est
comme si elle est pas du tout c'est
comme s'ils allaient faire de la plongée
en fait la même mais un truc un peu faim
mais je suis pas de mauvaise foi je me
dis que moi je suis heureux mais je dis
que moi ça me choque de devoir d'être
contraint de cacher son corps c'est
quelque chose sur le fond qui me choque
mais là je trouve qu'il ya un
détournement de la chose qui me paraît
intéressante
et qu'est-ce qui est le plus choquant
d'avoir des c'est parce que ces mêmes
marques elles vont faire des habits qui
vont couvrir la totalité du corps des
femmes mais elles vont faire des habits
aussi avec des jupes qui sont tout en
haut des cuisses quand les femmes
s'assoient donc on voit à peu près tout
dans sa maison du droit non mais c'est
un problème pour certaines de choix et
pour d'autres on lui a dit empêche de et
on les enferme dans dans ses vêtements
mais je pense que c est ce que c'est
respectueux pour la femme de leur
permettre de porter des jupes qui soit
florent serra
mais franchement il est un tout petit
peu net est ce que vous imaginez
vraiment que dans le magasin marks &
spencer et khalid qui va vendre détenus
islamistes
vous allez avoir un gros rayon de deux
mini jupe et de spring et bien sûr vous
plaisantez sera pas dans le même
quartier
on sait très bien que l'un se
substituera à l'autre je vous déciderez
un string dans un magasin marks &
spencer la seine saint denis c'est tout
voilà que vous n'en trouverez plus ces
valeurs là lorsque comme moi le mec vous
savez qu'il disait dans son roman la
différence des femmes occidentales et
les fameux arabes notamment c'est que la
femme occidentale est très bien habillé
la journée avec des talons roh décédé un
peu sexy et quand elles rentrent chez
elles et en jogging alors que ta femme
arabe qui est caché sous une burqa
la journée se met de techci chez elle la
nuit le soir il a estimé l'ex ça me
choque pas tant que ça et je pense qu'au
contraire le contournement il
détournement de
de ces principes un peu rigide ou en
fait faut qu'elle soit qu'elles soient
vilaine est moche dans ses habits moche
de leur donner quelque chose où elle
puisse est jolie je trouve que moi je
trouve que c'est plutôt pas mal même si
sur le fond je suis abandon une des
missions trop bien ça non je ne sais pas
en avant des missions seront contents de
contrôle social du corps des maillys
sécurisant des mandats c'est ce qu'elle
dit elle dit je crois que ces femmes
sont pour beaucoup d'entre elles des
militantes de l'islam politique je
trouve que c'est très excessif mais non
mais non il ya des tas de femmes qui
sont contraintes de porter ce type de
vêtement et elles sont pas des militants
et slam par meetic rapport au bout sous
tension c'est maintenant mais là c'est
stigmatiser temps des portables vous
auriez été pour que des gros couturier
face des costumes rayés plus simplement
du sénat parce que ça se passe comme tu
sais toi je voulais jouer sa place et le
marié d'accord ça se passe quand même
chez nous c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
des amis qui sont faits pour l'arabie
saoudite ou pour le dp comme ça c'est
des pays qui sont faits pour pour la
france ou pour le syndrome et pourquoi
pas 10 parce que c'est pas ce qui c'est
pas le droit de santé ses habits ne
devrait pas avoir les autres séquences
vidéo n'est pas l'idée qu'on se fait de
la femme en france
et heureusement mais rare dans ce cas là
il faut leur interdire de ses filles
comme ça si vous êtes dans votre logique
avec l'usure
je suis d'accord tout à fait d'accord
faut qu on note comme serveur de deux
aujourd'hui on est à l'herbier d'un sac
ou scié du bourg ce continent mais on
peut pas dire je tombais dans ce cas là
on ferme et on ferme les frontières paf
aller jusqu'au bout de votre réseau
maintenant de là mondialisée si vous
allez dans des pays
si vous avez des pays comme l'arabie
saoudite ou des objets de mettre un
voile une jupe longue et aidé à vous
cacher mais c'est pas nous c'est nous on
pourrait dire il n'y a pas de voile
toujours t il n'y a pas de yapen
souviendra dans ce pays
c'est tout lui pardonner mais là vous ne
parlez plus de la même chose non un peu
vous êtes vous êtes en effet sur la
question de la prestation rigoriste voir
intégristes de préceptes religieux
alors ça c'est un truc mais moi je vous
suis là dessus en revanche sur le fait
que des enseignes commerciales
s'engouffre dans ce dans ce dans ce
filon mais que pour pourquoi sommes nous
étonner enfin je veux dire je lui il ya
de l'argent à faire partout et dans tous
et j'en ai fait du bien de l'argent est
ce qu'on peut tous faire volte oui je
suis déprimé
c'est oui à mi-distance et des rêves
j'en avais est ce qu est la seconde
largeron du aucun ace qui ont de
l'argent ou petit panneau principe ce
sens est-ce que ça vous chathuant vous
croisez une indienne avec un très joli
sari à un voile est ce que vous êtes
choqués parce que c'est chatoyant parce
que c'est coloré est ce que ça vous
choque
mais encore une fois essayé de bonne foi
ça n'a rien à voir médias n'a rien à
voir rien à voir le statut de la femme
bien habillée que dont vous parlez
balade en europe en sari et pas tout à
fait celui de la la fille voilée de base
oui mais s'ils le font ils le font ils
un canton porter ça arrive c'est le même
fonds qu'elles portent pas du tout mais
c'est pas du tout les mecs sont habillés
pareil il reste quelques minutes après
six minutes
et si vous avez peut-être l'express de
cette semaine qui propose une vingtaine
de mesures là qui sont tirées pour
beaucoup de 2,2 du rapport attali enfin
des travaux qui laminent stéphane
évidemment mais mais je vais vous
interrogez quand même sur un certain
nombre de mesures qui comme verra
peut-être proposer pendant pendant la
campagne présidentielle y en a une dont
on parle beaucoup sur des institutions
c'est le retour au mandat présidentiel
de sept ans non renouvelable et beaucoup
de candidats qui se prononcent pour en
disant voilà au moins six et non
renouvelables je ferai ce que j'ai à
faire et je ne penserai pas mal
élections et puis c'est ans et un temps
plus long qui permet de faire des choses
même si woods qu il pourrait y avoir une
crue utilisation dans ce cas là si tous
un peu inquiétant parce que si on si on
fait qu'un seul mandat
c'est à dire que dès le lendemain de
l'élection du président qui ne fera
qu'un seul mandat
c'est déjà la curée pour savoir qui va
se présenter à la fin de son mandat donc
il n'y a aucune possibilité est un
président pressé dire que ce qu'on voit
un peu aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
beaucoup de gens qui pensent qu'au
volant ne pourra pas se représenter et
donc n'a pas vraiment quand pour voir
exactement
donc c'est là c'est le risque et puis il
ya une vie un argument démocratiques
fortes à dire que les mandats nous
renouvelables il faut s'en méfier parce
que le caractère renouvelable du mandat
permet au corps électoral de sanctionner
c'est à dire que si le président en
place au bout de sept ans souhaite
remettre ça il doit se représenter
devant le corps électoral et c'est
plutôt sain donc quelle que soit la
durée 7 5 ou enfin je pense que le
quinquennat était une erreur et que le
septennat était plutôt une bonne formule
et que la cohabitation n'était pas si
improductives autres guillemets que cela
ça rejoint le débat qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure sur l'exigence de classe et être
libye cités par les français oui alors
ça aussi c'était une façon de faire
travailler les gens à l'aise en réalité
il ne travaillait pas du tout non mais
ils avaient là on avait la pression oui
une passion d'enfance cordes et des
causses pop une guerre sanglante en
réalité ces colonnes mais qui pouvait
être assez drôle mais lol cette idée
deux septennats tiers de déconnexion
entre les élections législatives et
l'élection présidentielle moi me semble
plutôt une bonne idée oui en tout cas ce
que vous disiez tout à la corde aisée le
président français a tous les pouvoirs
il les a d'autant plus qu'il a une
majorité qui est qui est dit sol à lui
voir avec les entendu il ya presque plus
aucun
aucun obstacle enfin c'est l'histoire
des contre-pouvoirs vrai quoi c'est pas
tant le la séparation qui est importante
que les contre-pouvoirs faut que seul le
pouvoir arrête le pouvoir
oui bah de moi je pense que cette temps
me paraît mieux que 5,5 ça me paraît
vraiment extrêmement court pour pouvoir
mener un projet maintenant quand vous
souvenez quand même on avait envie de
faire correspondre un peu d'abord à ce
qui se passait à peu près partout
puisque les mandats présidentiels sont à
peu près sur plus court confiance sept
ans ça n'existait presque nulle part et
c'était une sorte d exigence
démocratique
mais pour sûr les législatives oui mais
oui personne ne peut prouver on peut
faire recomposer une fois cette une fois
de plus je trouve c'est un peu curieux
non non c'est beaucoup non
la suisse s'est intéressé aux rues dans
la bouche des tirades à ces derniers qui
se propose de ne faire qu'un seul mandat
parce qu'il ya un côté un peu un peu
bizarre à dire
l'arnaqué est basée en disant ça résonne
à dire votez pour moi ou elle sut
sûrement pas le meilleur mais vous
inquiétez pas ça va pas durer
mais c'est sa terrible d'un côté oui
bien que ce n'est pas un trop grand mais
c'est terrible mais en face qui veut
dire surtout c'est que comme je ne me
représenterai pas tout ce que je dis je
vais le faire normalement oui oui passé
ce qui permet de remplacer parce que
j'espère est ce que j l'ue à repenser ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est que dès
qu'on est élu au repos ça sert je pense
que c'est une journée magnifique il est
l'homme politique actuelle qui
accepteraient vraiment d'être
impopulaires même lui-même juppé après
une émission où on me dit que les
français les mecs bien qui avait une
petite larme à l'oeil
donc il ya aussi l'allégement du
parlement qui propose de passer de jeu
quand le nombre des députés est de 100
et le nombre de sénateurs à 5 ans ça
c'est n'importe quoi
oui c'est un pardon d'être aussi
catégorique parce que je sais ce que
c'est une question de coût oui coûte
cher c'est pas les élus c'est les agents
publics
d'une façon générale jean luc n'est pas
là c'est dommage s'est passé pas les
élus qui coûte cher donc 200 députés au
lieu de 577 est pas là dessus qu'on fera
des économies substantielles et on peut
déjà alors mais pourquoi pas 10 pourquoi
pas 10 députés à sont là ça coûterait
encore même cher non mais c'est vrai nom
mais deux sens mais pourquoi je
comprends pas l'argument ne sache
comprend pas et pourtant c'est un
argument très répandue on trouve souvent
dans les programmes voilà il ya trop
d'élus mais pourquoi évidemment pour le
statu quo non là je pense qu'on voudrait
prêter à discussion la prochaine foire
ce qui est intéressant du 6 et ses deux
de ne changer les règles sur l'impôt sur
la fortune entre l'immobilier les
oeuvres d'art alors ça aussi on peut en
parler longuement sans pareil
l'économique monde une curiosité et bah
je propose que la prochaine fois on
reprenne quelques unes de ses mesures
quand on leur parle puisque là le temps
qui nous est imparti
c'est malheureusement écoulé contre
merci à tous les trois et à très vite
pour un nouveau pacte